the production of Thor laughs and
thunder is slowly but surely progressing
in an interview with variety director
Taika Waititi spoke now about the
upcoming production start according to
his own statement the production will
start in Australia this summer and he
himself will be in Sydney in April
already the only thing that could
postpone the start of the production are
the ongoing bushfires in Australia which
are beyond his control
anyway furthermore a rumor about the
cast is currently circulating because
besides the top class actors like Chris
Hemsworth Natalie Portman and Tessa
Thompson another world-class actor could
join the cast namely Christian Bale
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
Welshman is currently under discussion
for a role that is not yet known but
there is no official confirmation from
Marvel or Disney yet the net community
has been wanting a better a bill
appearance for some time now similar to
the comic template the alien would first
land could be considered a villain due
to his frightening appearance has been
playing a role in the Marvel world since
the 80s similar to Jane Foster he also
seems to be worthy enough to lift
Mjolnir but he has his own powerful
weapon called storm breaker which is
surely known to all Thor fans however is
this road suitable for bait
hard to say because an actor with
bayless reputation wouldn't be necessary
to impersonate better rebel after all
the aliens face will be covered by a
mask or CGI effects on the other hand
there are also enough examples in the
MCU which show that many actors lent
their voices to the characters but are
invisible themselves the best examples
are Vin Diesel and Bradley Cooper who
can be heard but not seen with the
characters Groot and Rocket Raccoon Thor
laugh and thunder will be released in
u.s. cinemas on November 5th 2021 On
January 5th the Golden Globes were
awarded for the 77th time in the
following we give you a small overview
of the most important winners announced
by the satirically critical hosting of
Ricky Gervais this year it can be
observed that the prize did not go to a
few big productions but was distributed
to many different projects once upon a
time in Hollywood won three times in the
categories Best Picture comedy Best
Screenplay and for the performance of
Brad Pitt also Best Supporting Actor the
music via epic rocket
man one two Golden Globes in the
category Best Actor for Taron Egerton
performance and Best Original Song for
I'm gonna love me again director Sam
Mendes also had every reason to be happy
because his World War drama
1917 won in the category Best Drama
while he himself was crowned Best
Director not surprisingly the Joker are
very sad shocked in Phoenix of course
also one he got the Award Best Actor
drama more surprisingly however rapper
and actress
aquafina took home a Golden Globe as
Best Actress comedy as the first Asian
actress ever
what's also astonishing is the poor
performance of Netflix which only
received two prizes out of several
nominations the Mafia epic the Irishman
on the other hand went away completely
empty-handed of course there are many
more winners but this would go beyond
the scope of this list it remains to be
seen to what extent the Golden Globe
winners will be able to put an Oscar on
their chimney-piece in a few weeks time
as well this year's Academy Awards will
take place in the famous Dolby Theatre
in Los Angeles on February 9th first of
all it should be said that the Joker
movie with jerk in Phoenix stands
completely on its own of course this
means that there is no overlap with
other DC EU films however this does not
exclude the possibility that a Batman
could also exist in the world of Joker
we've already seen little Bruce Wayne in
the Joker movie director Todd Phillips
now announced in an interview with
variety that he could definitely imagine
the Batman in his Gotham City after all
his version of the city's beautiful but
he immediately stated that he would not
be the suitable director for this
understandable since he's not sure if he
wants to make a Joker - at all not to
mention a Batman movie hasty news
portals already announced during the
cinema release of Joker that a second
part has been decided nevertheless Todd
Phillips quickly contradicted those
rumors because according to his own
statement the current state of affairs
is that all sides are open for talks but
nothing more after Avengers endgame
James Cameron's blockbuster avatar is
the most successful cinema film of all
time with box-office takings of 2.7
billion u.s. dollars no wonder that the
avatar brand still holds a certain
fascination even though it was released
more than 10 years ago now new concept
images have been part
on avatars official Twitter account
showing the impressive world of Nabi
among other things you can see
representatives of the Navi people
flying around on insect like animals
riding through the water on the necks of
dinosaur-like creatures or watching the
sunset on a steep slope all in all very
pretty pictures which will hardly be
seen in the movies since they are only
concept pictures so far it will be
exciting to see how star director James
Cameron will implement his story in the
four sequels he's announced so far on
the actor side Sam Worthington and Zoe
Saldana are two familiar faces while
Kate Winslet's a new end especially
world famous actress is joining the cast
if the already planned sequels avatar
two and three will achieve the necessary
box office results avatar four and five
will follow after all Cameron has
expanded his story to a total of five
parts and according to his own statement
he's already completed the concept the
cinema release of avatar 2 is on
December 17 2021 while the third part is
supposed to be released on December 22nd
2023 whether and how things will
continue then will mainly depend on how
the avatar brand will be received by
viewers after so many years no one has
ever achieved this before Disney is now
officially considered the first
Hollywood studio to have made more than
ten billion u.s. dollars in a calendar
year the giant company is thus raising a
practically unsurpassable mark as last
year the turnover was about 13 billion
u.s. dollars the surprising part is that
the record in this case is not dependent
on individual films like Star Wars 9 or
Spider Man far from home instead the
sales are continuously high which means
that Disney's delivered one hit after
another at least financially in the
following small chop 5 of the most
successful Disney movies of 2019
Avengers end game 2.7 eight billion u.s.
dollars The Lion King one point six six
billion US dollars frozen to one point
two three billion u.s. dollars Captain
Marvel 1.13 billion u.s. dollars and the
Toy Story 1.0 seven billion u.s. dollars
by the way the takeover of 20th Century
Fox by Disney had no significant impact
on sales as the sales of the two Studios
were still calculated separately for the
calendar year 2019 start
this year they will be merged and it is
to be expected that not only the [ __ ]
take over but also the upcoming Marvel
films will further increase the sales
curve with the franchise as large as
star wars it's now commonplace that
every piece of new information triggers
great emotions in fans
some people excitedly come up their own
conspiracy theories and speculations
while others are usually skeptical
towards new developments right from the
outset the site making Star Wars and its
operator Jason Ward who've proven to be
quite trustworthy in the past have now
provided new material for the rumor mill
it's already known that Lucasfilm wants
to introduce a new era in the Star Wars
universe according to what this will go
back about 400 years in time and we'll
start from Episode one The Phantom
Menace also visually a lot is supposed
to change as many viewers complained
that episode 79 had the rather outdated
look of the original trilogy in terms of
content the film should also be able to
stand for themselves in the future and
will no longer appear only in trilogies
yet at the same time the films should
remain connected by the common epic this
reminds very much of Marvel's shared
universe in which the films coexist
perfectly only that Marvel also has the
advantage that they can fall back on an
almost endless pool of comic artwork the
question is will this also work for Star
Wars another rumor of Ward is the
mysterious project luminous Allegiant
Lee several Star Wars authors are
supposed to work on a collaborative
story that can be extended to books
comics and computer games in terms of
content the stories are supposed to take
place between 300 and 400 years before
the Skywalker saga and are supposed to
be very diversified in one of the
stories a group of Jedi is supposed to
go on a journey of discovery into the
dangerous unknown regions
[Music]